hey 42 here Facebook has 1.4 billion
active uses that means one fit for verse
population has a Facebook account let's
find out some mind-blowing facts about
the social networking giant the average
user spends 40 minutes a day on Facebook
some people spend so much time on
Facebook that there is actually a
medically recognized condition called
fad or Facebook addiction disorder that
is someone whom is wholly reliant on
Facebook and spend more than 3 hours a
day on it there are estimated to be
around 350 million people in the world
unknowingly suffering from Facebook
addiction disorder a common symptom of
fad is adding complete strangers as
friends to artificially inflates their
friend count in fact research has shown
that 80% of people on the friends list
of people who suffer from fad are fake
friends 600,000 hacking attempts are
made on Facebook accounts every single
day
Facebook will actually pay you if you
successfully hack their website and
report the details of your hack to
Facebook
this helps Facebook uncover books and
fix security holes before other hackers
with more malicious intentions finds
them and abuse them Facebook will pay
you anywhere between $500 and 40
thousand dollars if you can hack their
site depending on the severity of the
book al pacino was the first ever face
to appear on Facebook he appeared in the
header of the original website nobody is
really sure why Zuckerberg chose Al
Pacino on average every Facebook user is
separated by only 3 point 7 4 degrees of
separation from every
over Facebook user or to put it in
another way if you take any of a
Facebook user in the world they are
friends with someone who is friends with
another person who is friends with
someone else who has a friend that is
also a friend of yours you can't block
mark zuckerberg on facebook attempting
to do so will display an error message
the facebook like button was originally
going to be called the awesome button in
2005 myspace was engaged in talks to buy
Facebook but they rejected mark
zuckerberg zas 'king price of 75 million
dollars as too expensive facebook now
brings in a colossal three billion
dollars in revenue every quarter
Facebook has a whole 1 billion more
users than Twitter does amongst
Facebook's huge feature set used to be a
peer-to-peer file-sharing service called
wire hop when Facebook launched in 2004
users could have blowed files to their
account then share them with their
Facebook friends
however wire hug was eventually axed in
2006 due to security concerns similar to
Google Facebook employees get three
completely free meals a day as well as
free drinks cooked by the self entitled
Facebook culinary team there's actually
a Facebook app to see what's on the menu
at the Facebook headquarters each day so
Facebook employees don't even need to
leave their seats to order lunch it's
called the lunchtime up don't worry
Facebook employees if you get fired from
Facebook you can always sell your hoodie
a standard issue facebook employee
hoodie sold on ebay for a whopping 4050
dollars with 50 bidders battling it out
what Facebook also has a few dark
secrets Facebook tracks almost every
site you
visit by using javascript iframes
and cookies it can even track you when
you're logged out this is how Facebook
shows you those ridiculously accurate
adverts and know stuff about you that
seemed unbelievably invasive such as
when you're pregnant or where you're
planning to go on holiday there have
also been allegations that Facebook
automatically scans your private
messages to build up an overall picture
of what you're interested in so that
they can show you more accurate
advertisements although Facebook has
denied this behavior the astonishing
accuracy of their adverts seems to
suggest otherwise even more shocking
there have been cases of people being
murdered because they intended someone
on Facebook one such case was in 2012
when a couple unfriended a woman on
Facebook
the unfriended woman's father was so
angered by this that he went to the
couple's house and shot them both there
was also the shocking case of a woman
who set fire to her best friend's house
after being unfriended on Facebook
Facebook is also responsible for an
enormous amount of divorces a
frightening study showed that Facebook
was a major contributing factor in up to
one-third of all divorces also all this
Facebook use may not be as good for you
as you think a study suggested that 1 in
3 people feel more dissatisfied with
their lives after visiting Facebook also
a study showed that 25% of Facebook
users have been dumped on Facebook at
one point and what's even more worrying
is that it's becoming increasingly
common for people to end relationships
by simply changing their facebook status
from in a relationship to single and
finally there is strong evidence to
suggest that Facebook is dumbing down
Society
but study conducted at the ohio state
university showed that the average
grades of students who use facebook
where a whole grade lower than students
who don't use facebook thanks for the
view subscribe for more thoughty2
you